joining me here on the rich eisen show
is the head coach of the saint peters
peacocks who busted many many brackets
but i'm sure he does not care at all he
is shaheen holloway how are you coach
doing well thanks for having me on you
got it so what did you tell your team
going into this game
you know what i told i told us i tried
the next one that's caught they had some
fun
scott didn't make history um you know we
came in with some momentum we won
you know eight games in a row you know i
know if if we could you know we're
standing day running for the first seven
minutes we have a good chance and
you know the team the team had a lot a
lot of confidence they had a lot of
confidence
well you could definitely see it that
they they had a lot of confidence right
right from uh right from the first
tip right i mean so uh the uh your your
game plan uh going against kentucky and
how it worked out was what
you know what the game plan was
the game plan would just go in and just
you know play saint peter's basketball
you know you know um you know i got a
bunch of guys on my team that
played with it with a
chip on their shoulder you know some of
my guys my team think they belong at
kentucky
you know for whatever reason right so
you know we just went out there and just
just wanted to play same thing as
basketball we wanted to play our defense
we wanted one to play just
and then just got to play and i think i
think the second half we kind of did
that okay so then uh and then obviously
uh down eight with three minutes to go
um
you know
i'm wondering how you as a coach who
knows the ebbs and flows of a game
uh were was able to get your guys uh
focused or how your guys focused uh on
their own potentially to get this game
into overtime at the very least
well you know what we kind of changed
our defense up
once we turned the defense up we kind of
got them stagnated a little bit and i
told them i said we could get two two
stops and two scores you know we're
going to be right back in this and we
did it
um you know and then we got right back
in it i think we actually had a chance
to win before overtime you know if we
could've got a rebound
uh we didn't get a defensive rebound
they got it and threw it out hit a three
you know and that's how they got the
lead but um you know this is about games
and runs i told these guys by gamer run
i said you guys put yourself in a
position to win the game
go out there and win it
shaheen holloway the head coach of the
saint peter's peacocks who just uh
pulled off a major upset uh the first
major upset and perhaps the biggest
major upset we're going to see in this
tournament right here on the uh rich
eisen show so uh which kid
has a story that you met
you didn't know and then you heard about
and you recruited them to your team and
just bawled out last night you got a
good story for that people may not know
i know you don't want to see someone i
think i think most of the guys are like
that right if you look at my team you
know we got it's a bunch of guys on my
team that was under recruited
um a lot of guys that you know didn't
have a lot of d1 offers
um so they came to play for me they
believed in my vision
um you know and they got better each
year and that's not kind of that that's
the blueprint of you know how we did
things at seton hall
i'm doing things now and you kind of get
guys that's underrecruited and make them
better so you know it's not just one guy
i mean i mean
the whole team has a story
and then again your story uh shaheen you
just mentioned seton hall did uh
calipari try to recruit you at umass
back in the day did you ever hear me did
did caliber
yeah
he recruited one of my teammates winston
smith
um
when he was at umass um he tells the
story that i was too good to go there so
you he wants to recruited me
but um
but now he recruited one of my teammates
once to smith okay so
i just took a shot just to see if coach
cal might have strolled into your living
room or something like that way back in
the day and now you've kind of stood in
his way in 2022
you know it's kind of nice
no he recruited one of my teammates so
no i knew coach kyle for a long time
well i mean
yeah coach what do you mean he's your
guy what'd you say i said he's a good
guy heck of a coach right um and so back
in your day um
as well shaheen you were the mvp of the
1996 mcdonald's uh all-american game and
on your team that you were the you you
won the mvp of but you i mean what a
stacked game that was kobe bryant was on
that team as well
what are your recollections of of being
a teammate of kobe back in the day
shaheen
you know kobe is a great guy you know
god bless dad you know i played with
kobe a lot
before them before the mcdonald's game
we play against each other a lot and
with each other a lot of all-star games
um that was a tremendous game just it
just has so many
uh big time players a lot of nba players
on that team
tim thomas rich hamilton
mike debbie
you know kobe
the list goes on and on and on and on um
you know we just was out there having
fun and just enjoying each other and
you know trying to get a chance to kind
of be normal you know at that time
all of us was
you know high profile high school
basketball players so it was really hard
to try to be a normal high school kid so
now when you when you when you're around
a group that's
kind of went through this thing that you
went through like that whole weekend
they were just out there enjoying each
other could be having fun yeah yeah i'm
looking at the
the roster of your team was kobe rip
hamilton stephen jackson jermaine o'neal
tim thomas and you were the
i mean good lord
yeah it's crazy
i mean you know that that's a big mac
right there no question about that and
so do
do you show any of your old
footage or film to your team no you know
what you know what no i try not to do
that i try to make it about them some
things that come up on the internet and
they come down and ask me about it i
kind of downplayed a little bit
but now you know i don't really i don't
really talk about my career because i
wanted i wanted to be all about these
guys and
the work that they put in and you know
for them
and so um when it was all over who did
you hear from coach holloway who did you
hear from from back in the day
but
when what was all over when when the
game was all over yesterday when you
look down at your phone maybe who would
you hear from oh oh man
i had
781 texts
[Laughter]
did you say 781 is that what you said
780 781
oh my god
well i'm honored that one of them being
from uh the rich eisen show booking
staff uh me may have uh gotten to you so
uh you gotta you got a couple names that
have people that that reached out to you
that uh no you know just a bunch of
family and friends and co-workers and
you know coaches that that's in the
business that i
was uh friends with um you know just you
know people that support me
support the program you know people like
that
okay and so uh next up is murray state
i'm sure you you spent uh a lot of time
deep into the night watching that game
um
what do you tell your team about not
just letting this uh win soul win define
you and your team coach well we came
down here on a mission to
to win two games um you know one game at
a time murray state is a great program
he's been a great program for a long
time now um top 25 program you know
coach does a great job over there we
just got to come out and play saint
peter's basketball you know i was i've
been on watching them one night sorry
that my voice sounded like this i'm a
little horse right now it's all good you
know um
now you know what um you know they are
great programs it's going to be a heck
of a game i mean we put some
similarities into styles you know they
played 10 guys we played 10 11 guys
um you know they pressed we pressed you
know but did they like to obviously get
up and down a little bit more and we
like to play defense so you know we got
to make sure that we understand the
discount report and the game plan and
kind of go from there coach
congratulations on the w appreciate the
time i know you're a busy man good luck
against murray state and uh
i i i just have to full disclosure you
destroyed my bracket and i just wanted
to tell you that myself
i told everybody i told everybody i told
everyone who asked me
do not bet on us i told them that don't
don't during the season i don't know
what team is going to show up myself
line of the day sir we call that a mic
drop uh thank you so much coach uh let's
let's chat again soon congratulations
and uh say hi to everybody back in
jersey city and uh and the east coast
you take care thank you guys so much you
got us shaheen holloway everybody head
coach of st peters right here on the
rich eisen show hey you watched all the
way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here